Toyota's new pro ace verso MPV now has
more to offer the van is not only
available in two versions it also comes
in three different body lengths ranging
between four point six and five point
three meters
didn't home car tester on delayed
cinnamon praises the interior which he
says meets passenger car standards he
has a slight beef with the position of
the bottle holders though their
dashboard location means he has to lean
forward to reach them he says putting
them in the door would have been more
practical recently sent for Lego phone
one very practical aspect is the
relatively slender body width of 1.92
with a turning circle of 11 meters this
vehicle is highly maneuverable in city
traffic
the Toyotas front is reminiscent of its
German rivals from VW and Mercedes the
compact version we tested has eight
seats and is 4.6 meters long with a
wheelbase of 2.9 meters that makes the
pro-ice vessel the shortest van in its
segment off the hook Andre says a ride
in the back is an experience worth
having
not only do passengers have room in all
directions but the design concept
includes large windows his favorite
feature is the panoramic roof making a
drive around the city a real sightseeing
tour the driver's seat is definitely not
that of a typical van the Toyota pro ace
van has 110 kilowatts of power giving it
a maximum speed of 170 kilometers an
hour the sprint from 0 to 100 takes 11
seconds the vehicle consumes an average
of 5 point 3 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers
the priceless Andre describes the
pro-ice vessel as easy to maneuver with
effortless steering but he finds the
gearbox action a bit rough shifting
could be smoother as far as he's
concerned but it's precise mr [ __ ]
I'm light vans are becoming more and
more popular on the European market and
the pro ways can rival the best of them
mr. David Andre says the three body
links and the choice of station wagon or
platform cab versions mean the pro ace
is poaching not only in VW's t6 hunting
grounds but also taking on the smaller
VW Caddy as well at heights of less than
1.9 meters the Pro ace is no problem for
underground or multi-story garages and
the low price makes it a real
alternative to the leading brands